I just think that we're selling this
idea to women that you know
contraception can be used for all these
good things it's like okay I hear what
you're saying it can relieve symptoms
but we can't ignore the fact that we're
just talking about symptoms that present
on the surface none of this is actually
tackling any underlying cause and
unfortunately that's the world we live
in no one's going to talk about the
underlying cause because look I've said
it before I say it again a sick patient
is a returning customer and that will
continue to be the consensus for our
society because it's the world we live
in everything revolves around money